them a little
to mature for a [ __ ] stamp but I I have
one yeah Travis Barker isn't the only
Inked member of the Kardashian crew ding
ding ding did I win Kris Jenner's
rocking one too she was tuned in because
you never know what's gonna happen the
famous momager opens up about that tat
right above her booty on the latest
episode of Hulu's the Kardashians during
a chat with her daughter Courtney and
courts now hubby Travis Barker wait what
does that say on your forehead family
loyalty responsibility respect I have
his tattoos memorized do you still have
your attention I do yep in those days
they called it a [ __ ] stamp but um I
think I'm a little
too mature for a [ __ ] stamp but I I
have one and now a quick trip down
Kardashian tat Memory Lane last year
Chris revealed that she and Chloe had
matching crosses but Coco had hers
lasered off who's gotten matching
tattoos
me and Chloe what is it what's it a
tattoo of where is it's a cross and
where is it
oh my booty and long time fans of the
family recall that during season two of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians the mom
of six got Kendall and Kylie's names
etched on her back during a girls night
out my problem is I have like 32
children so how do you put everybody's
name on your body you don't and you know
what I'm not so happy with the older
kids right now so Kendall and Kylie get
names and Kim and Courtney and Chloe
don't looks like we know who her
favorite daughters are well at least on
that day I'm proud of all my kids
earlier this month Chris played Coy when
asked about her six kiddos you know what
every day I have a different favorite
but shortly after that she was singing a
different tune when she and Kylie
stopped by The Late Late Show with James
Corden and took a lie detector test am I
your favorite child
yes
true
[Applause]
[Music]